autrement dit, le risque représenté par la route,
n'est que légèrement plus importante.
Et cette toute petite différence dans la règle individuelle de mouvement
suffit à expliquer ce que nous observons,
le fait que la femelle dominante mène son groupe à la route,
et laisse ensuite place aux autres,
pour qu'ils traversent en premier.
George Box, un statisticien anglais, a écrit :
« Tous les modèles sont faux, mais certains sont utiles. »
Et en fait, ce modèle est évidemment faux.
Car en réalité, les suricates sont tout sauf des particules aléatoires.
Mais il est également utile, car il nous dit que la simplicité extrême
de règles de mouvement à un niveau individuel
peuvent conduire à une importante complexité au niveau du groupe.
Encore une fois, c'est la simplification de la complexité.
J'aimerais conclure par ce que ça signifie pour l'ensemble de l'espèce.
Lorsque la femelle dominante laisse la place aux subalternes,
ce n'est pas par politesse.
En fait, la femelle dominante est extrêmement importante
pour la cohésion du groupe.
Si elle meurt sur la route, tout le groupe sera en danger.
Ce comportement de prévention de risque est une réponse évolutive très ancienne.
Ces suricates reproduisent une tactique qui a évolué dans le temps,
vieille de milliers de générations, et ils l'adaptent à un risque moderne,
dans ce cas, une route construite par des êtres humains.
Ils adaptent des règles très simples, et le comportement complexe en découlant
leur permet de résister à l’empiétement des humains sur leur habitat naturel.
Au bout du compte,
il peut s'agir de chauves-souris qui changent leur structure sociale
pour répondre à un effondrement de leur population ;
ou il peut s'agir de suricates
qui déploient une nouvelle adaptation aux routes humaines,
ou il peut s'agir d'une autre espèce.
Mon message n'est pas compliqué, mais c'est un message simple
d'émerveillement et d'espoir.
Mon message est que les animaux démontrent une complexité sociale extraordinaire,
et ça leur permet de s'adapter
et de réagir aux changements dans leur environnement.
En trois mots, dans le monde animal, la simplicité mène à la complexité
qui débouche sur la résilience.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Dania Gerhardt : Nicolas, merci beaucoup pour ce formidable début.
Vous êtes un peu nerveux ?
Nicolas Perony : Ça va, merci.
DG : Super.
Je suis sure que de nombreuses personnes dans le public
ont essayé d'une certaine façon
d'établir des liens entre les animaux dont vous parliez,
les chauve-souris, les suricates, et les humains.
Vous avez montré des exemples.
Les femelles sont les membres sociaux, les membres dominants,
je ne sais pas bien qui pense comment, mais bon.
A-t-on raison de faire ces liens ?
Y a-t-il des clichés que vous pouvez confirmer à cet égard
qui sont peut-être valables pour toutes les espèces ?
NP : Je voudrais dire qu'il y a des contre-exemples
dans ces stéréotypes.
Par exemple, chez les hippocampes ou chez les koalas,
ce sont en fait les mâles qui s'occupent des jeunes, tout le temps.
La leçon à en tirer,
c'est que c'est souvent difficile et parfois un peu dangereux
de faire des parallèles entre les humains et les animaux. Voilà.
DG : Très bien. Merci beaucoup pour cet excellent début.
Merci Nicolas Perony.